des produits non respect par les
religieux à l'intérieur du coup vous
êtes d'analyser sa session la
concurrence déloyale de la banane
martiniquaise face aux bananes ce une
américaine une problématique que connaît
bien le député jean christophe lagarde
par exemple cet exploitant agricole qui
produit de la banane conventionnelle
utilise deux fois moins de pesticides
que d'autres banane biologique
étrangères on impose des règles ici
qu'on n'impose pas à la république
dominicaine lorsqu'elle importe les
bananes en europe ça c'est ce qu'il faut
cesser c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
défendre pendant les élections
européennes en disant on peut
s'appliquer des règles strictes à nous
pour protéger le consommateur
mais on peut pas accepter d'importer des
choses qui ne respectent pas les règles
qu'on oblige à nos producteurs ça c'est
le plus grand scandale c'est une
difficulté puisque nous voyons qu ici on
se bat pour faire une banane ou vraiment
sans pesticides sans une banane pomme
banane qu'ecolo est que sur le marché
français nous rencontrons des bananes
soi-disant bio qui ne sont pas
véritablement abordé les problématiques
locales rencontrer ses adhérents et
soutenir philippe petit aux élections
municipales à ducos
tel est le programme du député mais le
président de l'union des démocrates et
des indépendants vis déjà plus loin
il va rencontrer différentes figures
politiques de tous bords comme didier
laguerre serge letchimy ou jean-michel
j'ai mieux ce sont des rencontres qui
chantent dix ans contre une intelligence
dans pour la commune où les municipales
maintenant est ce qu'il y aura d'autres
discussions où la ctm ou d'autres choses
à venir je ne peux pas vous dire au
moins le contact est pris il est établi
et je crois que c'est l'hospitalité
philippe qui va encore tenter sa chance
pour diriger la ville de ducos alors que
le maire sortant charles andré mancey ne
se représente pas la bataille sera dure
il devra composer avec les ambitions de
marius narciso aurélie n'est la wilfrid
sina où louis marie sainte